Prof: Okay,
at the end last time we were
looking at how you could
possibly know the heat of
atomization of graphite;
how much energy it takes to put
a carbon atom into the gas phase
from graphite.
Why would you want to know that?
Why is that a key value?
For what purpose?
If you want to be able to know
whether you can add together
bonds and get the energy of a
molecule,
that means you start with
separated atoms and you then see
how much energy is given off
when those come together to give
a particular molecule,
to make a whole bunch of bonds.
Right?
Now you can measure the energy
of a molecule with respect to
CO_2 quite easily.
How do you do that?
Burn it.
And you can measure the CO_2
relative to graphite.
How do you do that?
How do you know the energy of a
carbon in -- or the energy of
CO_2 relative to the energy of
graphite plus oxygen?
You burn graphite. Okay?
But the last thing you need is
the energy of graphite relative
to the atom.
And if you then knew that,
then you could complete this
scheme and know,
just by burning things,
whether you can add together
bond energies to get the energy
of a molecule.
Okay, so how do you get the
energy from graphite to an atom?
One way is spectroscopy,
and we talked about that last
time,
that if you see what the
minimum amount of energy you can
put into CO_2 and have it break
into two atoms,
that gives you the energy of
the two atoms relative to CO_2
--
pardon me, relative to CO I
should be saying.
Right?
And then you burn CO and get it
relative to CO_2,
and then you have everything
you need.
Okay?
Okay, except that people who
were very smart,
Nobel Prize winners and so on,
differed on interpreting this,
because some of them thought
that when you break into atoms,
with the light,
the atom you get is not the
lowest energy state of the atom,
but a higher energy state of
the atom.
So some of the energy you're
putting in is going into making
an excited atom.
And the true energy of forming
the minimum-energy carbon atom
from graphite is lower than what
you do spectroscopically.
So the spectroscopic value is
very precise.
You can measure the position,
the color of the light,
very accurately.
But they didn't know what it
corresponded to,
so they needed a different way
to know what the energy of the
carbon atom was relative to
graphite.
Now Professor Sharpless said --
you know, he talked about
increasing dimension of carbon;
start with an atom,
go to a line,
polyacetylene and then to a
bunch of double bonds,
and finally to a saturated
hydrocarbon --
he said that carbon atoms are
very hard to come by.
You need a really,
really low vacuum to get it.
Right?
That is, the equilibrium
constant for carbon atoms coming
together to form bonds is very,
very favorable.
Right?
So it's hard to get atoms.
So how are you ever going to
get atoms?
Well let's think about that
problem here.
So we know that the equilibrium
constant at room temperature is
10^-(3/4)ΔE.
So you can measure k.
Then you know ΔE.
So, but if the equilibrium
you're trying to measure is
between graphite and carbon
atoms,
and the energy to take a carbon
atom out of graphite is 170
kilocalories/mol,
then the equilibrium constant
is 10^-127.
Right?
And that means,
since there are only something
of the order of 10^80 atoms in
the universe,
there would not be,
at room temperature,
a single carbon atom at
equilibrium with graphite if
everything in the universe was
graphite.
Right?
So it's not a very favorable
equilibrium constant.
What could you do about it,
if you wanted to measure the
equilibrium constant,
and in that way get the energy
difference?
Any knobs you can twist?
Lucas?
Student:  Temperature.
Prof: You could increase
the temperature.
Right?
Because it's ΔE/kT.
And remember,
we're talking about room
temperature.
So if we're much higher than
room temperature,
then the exponent gets much
smaller.
So suppose we went to ten times
room temperature,
to 3000 Kelvin.
Right?
Then it would be,
instead of 3/4ths,
it would be 3/40ths,
because the denominator would
be ten times bigger.
And now it would be 1 in
10^13th would be an atom.
And now that's a substantial
number, if you're talking about
Avogadro's number.
So if you had something really,
really sensitive,
to measure atoms,
you might be able to measure
the atoms at equilibrium.
But you have to establish
equilibrium at something of the
order of 3000°,
or at least really,
really hot.
Right?
So you could write the
equilibrium constant,
the concentration of atoms over
the concentration of graphite,
in this way.
That has to do -- that is the
heat of formation,
atoms relative to graphite.
Right?
Now, of course,
exactly what one means by the
concentration of graphite needs
to be -- you scratch your head a
little bit about that.
Right?
But you don't actually need to
know it,
because if you could measure
the pressure of the C atoms at
equilibrium with graphite,
at very high temperature --
call that the pressure of
carbon, right?
-- that is some constant,
and that constant will include
whatever this concentration of
graphite should be.
So B. So multiply both sides
by that concentration of
graphite.
Right?
So we get some constant on the
right, and then that heat of
formation, in the exponent,
that we want to find.
So that means we could write --
if we took the log of both
sides.
You have the log of the
pressure of carbon atoms,
is the log of whatever B is --
that's some constant -- minus
this other term.
And what that means is that if
you --
that that minus the heat of
formation of the carbon atom,
divided by R,
is the slope of a plot of the
pressure of carbon atoms,
versus 1/T.
Does everyone see that?
In that equation,
that equation says that there's
an intercept,
which is the log of b,
and a slope,
which is -ΔH
formation to carbon,
divided by R,
if you plot against 1/T.
Everybody with me on that?
Nod if you see it.
Okay.
So all you need to do is plot
the log of the pressure of
carbon atoms,
which will be very low,
versus 1/T,
at very high temperature --
right?;
of the order of 3000 Kelvin.
So that's not easy to do.
But it was done in 1955 by
Chupka and Inghram.
And this is the sketch of their
instrument, and I'll show you
how they did it.
First there's a graphite
cylinder.
Okay?
And around it is a can made out
of tantalum.
Now why tantalum?
Because that's about the
highest melting thing you can
get;
it's the highest melting metal.
So 3293 Kelvin is its melting
point.
So you could really heat the
heck out of this thing.
Okay?
And now you surround that with
wires, and those wires are made
of tungsten, because that's very
high melting too.
And so you connect wire -- you
connect electricity to the
tungsten, and also to the
tantalum.
So electrons boil off the
tungsten and bombard the
tantalum, and when the electrons
hit it, they heat it up.
So you can heat the heck out of
this tantalum can by bombarding
it with electrons.
And that, of course,
heats the graphite that's
inside.
Now, so inside there's going to
be a gas of carbon,
in equilibrium with the
graphite.
Now it won't just be C atoms.
It'll also be C_2,
C_3, C_60, C_70,
and so on;
but lots of different forms of
carbon, as a gas.
So you can't just measure the
pressure in there;
and indeed it would be tough to
measure the pressure inside,
at 3000°.
But you at least have these
things there at equilibrium.
Now what they did,
Chupka and Inghram,
was to drill a tiny hole,
in the top of this thing.
And that will allow a little
bit of the gas to escape;
not so much that you destroy
the equilibrium inside,
just a really slow leak.
Right?
So now, if you could measure
the amount of these different
carbon species leaking out,
you could know what the
pressure of them was inside the
can.
Okay?
Now, so there's a beam of
carbon species coming out,
gaseous carbon species.
This is all at very,
very high vacuum.
Right?
And then up there,
an electron beam comes across
and hits these carbon things,
and knocks electrons out of
them.
And that converts them into C+;
C_1, C_2, C_3, C_60+. Okay?
So you have a beam coming out
of these charged carbon species.
Now why do you want them to be
charged?
For two reasons.
One, so you can detect them;
because you can detect it when
charge hits a plate.
And the other one is so you can
deflect the beams with a
magnetic field.
Right?
So these various carbon species
come out, and they go into a
magnetic field,
which puts a lateral force on
them and causes them to bend.
And, of course,
the lighter they are,
the easier they are to bend if
they all have the same charge.
So you're going to get curved
trajectories.
C_3+, C_2+, C_1+ will be the
most bent.
And now if you put a detector
at these different positions,
you can see how much C_1,
how much C_2,
how much C_3 there was.
Okay?
So that's how you're going to
do it.
But this machine has to be
pretty special,
because you're heating it so
high.
Lucas?
Student:  How do you
know the electron beam only
knocks off one electron?
Prof: It can knock off
two, but then you get it at a
very different position.
You can tell these things.
This thing is called mass
spectroscopy.
But it knocks off one much more
often than it knocks off two or
three.
Student:  And isn't this
kind of the same problem as we
had with the other thing,
where the C is ionized?
Prof: Which other thing?
I can't remember what problem
--
Student:  You said that
we couldn't measure the other
one because it was a high energy
state, spectrographically.
Prof: Oh.
Might it be an excited state?
Student:  Yeah.
Prof: No because it's in
equilibrium.
Student:  Okay.
Prof: The excited state
would be much,
much less at equilibrium,
because it's higher in energy.
Right?
That's a good point though;
good that you thought about
that.
Now, so you have to put
shielding around this stuff,
so it doesn't melt everything.
So you use tantalum,
which is high melting,
and a series of
can-inside-a-can,
like Russian dolls.
Right?
So the inside most one is very,
very hot;
then a little less hot,
a little less hot.
Okay?
So you shield it.
And now you need to know the
temperature inside.
And you do it by drilling a
tiny hole through those shields
so you can have what's called an
optical pyrometer.
That's just something that
looks at the color of something
that's really hot.
And something that's hot gives
-- even something that's cold --
gives off black-body radiation.
And the color has to do with
the temperature;
you know, there's red heat,
white heat, blue heat,
and so on.
So by measuring the color,
you can see what the
temperature was inside.
And that window,
that the light comes through,
has to be made of quartz,
not Pyrex glass.
You know why?
Student:  Pyrex would
melt.
Prof: Because Pyrex
glass would melt,
even at that distance.
Right?
So you use quartz glass.
Okay, so that's what you do.
And here's a graph of the
pressure of these various
species,
measured with that mass
spectrometer,
at different temperatures,
measured as one over
temperature here.
So it goes from 2150 Kelvin to
2450 Kelvin, and the pressure
increases.
And it's plotted as the log of
the intensity of the signal;
that is, the pressure times
temperature, because the
pressure has to be corrected for
temperature.
Because if you have the same
number of things giving the
pressure, but they're hotter,
they'll be pressing harder on
things.
It's the intensity of the
signal times the temperature
that you plot there.
And from the slope,
you can see up there at the
top, that for C_1 you get -- the
slope says it's 171
kilocalories/mol;
Q.E.D.***Right?
Now you know which was the
right one, measured by
spectroscopy.
It was the one that said 171.
So this experiment,
actually measuring the
equilibrium between carbon atoms
and graphite,
by a really gargantuan kind of
experiment,
is what settled the question
finally.
So that when you look at the
appendix of this book,
Streitwieser,
Heathcock and Kosower,
you find that there are heats
of formation for atoms and
radicals,
measured by spectroscopy and
things like this.
And there you see carbon, 170.9.
And that was done by Professor
Chupka, who was in this
department and who used to come
and tell people how he did this
experiment.
But as you can see,
he passed away in 2007.
So thanks to Professor Chupka.
And the nice thing is,
once that's done,
it's done.
Now you know it and you just
plug it in when you burn your
stuff and want to know what its
energy is.
You can get it relative to
carbon atoms in the gas phase.
Okay, now how good are these
spectroscopic experiments?
Well this is a neat thing.
The heat of atomization of
methane, measured in the ways
we've just been talking about,
is 397.5 kilocalories/mol.
Now that comes from mating a
carbon atom with four hydrogen
atoms;
that is 397.5. Right?
So we know what the average
bond energy.
There are four such bonds.
So each one's worth 99.4
kilocalories/mol.
So about 100 kilocalories/mol
for a C-H bond;
that's convenient to remember.
Okay?
But that's not how much it
costs to take a single hydrogen
atom away from methane.
Taking a single hydrogen atom
away from methane,
the so-called "bond
dissociation energy",
which is the actual
experimental energy it takes to
do some particular process --
average bond energy is just an
average,
but the individual ones are not
the same --
taking a hydrogen away from
methane is 104.99,
plus or minus 0.03
kilocalories/mol.
Close, but not the same thing.
And then you have CH_3.
If you take a second H off
that, it's 110.4.
The next one is 101.3,
and the final one,
taking H away from C,
is only 80.9.
Right?
Now these are done by
spectroscopy.
And Barney Ellison may come and
talk to us in the spring;
he's often traveling through
and talks about how he measured
these things.
But those are done by
spectroscopy.
But the neat thing about it is
if you add all those four
numbers together -- so,
pardon me, I was going to say
no individual bond equals the
average.
Right?
But if you add them together
you get 397.5,
which is precisely the average.
So these are very good
experiments.
So we know, through heroic
spectroscopy and this work of
Chupka and Inghram,
we know what these energies
are, bond energies,
and bond dissociation energies.
So here are average bond
energies in a table that you
have at the end of this organic
chemistry text.
And it says a carbon-hydrogen
bond is 99;
and now you see where we get
that.
And you see that a
carbon-carbon bond is 83.
But the second carbon-carbon
bond, in a double bond,
is only 63.
Right?
Why is it weaker?
Why is the second bond of a
carbon-carbon double bond weaker
than the first?
Pardon me?
Devin, what do you say?
Student:  The overlap.
Prof: Yeah,
you have bad overlap between
the π electrons.
In fact, the first,
the single bond of a double
bond, is probably stronger than
a normal single bond.
Can anybody see why that would
be?
Student:  More s
character.
Prof: It's got more
s character,
better overlap;
sp^2-sp^2.
So the second one is probably
more than 20 kilocalories weaker
than the single one.
But at any rate it's 146,
that you add up to get a double
bond, and 200 for a triple bond;
which means the third bond is
worth only 54 kilocalories/mol.
Okay?
And in C=O, it's about the same
as C-C.
So C-O is eighty-six.
But the double bond,
notice, is different in this
case.
Now the second bond is stronger
than the first.
So the carbonyl group is an
especially stable group.
Okay?
So you have the question,
can you sum up these average
bond energies and get useful
heats of atomization?
So can you look at a structure
and say how stable it's going to
be?
Okay, so let's try it.
So here's heats of atomization
by additivity of average bond
energies.
So we have these average bond
energies from the table.
A C-C single-bond is 83.
A C-H is 99.
C double bond C is 146,86,
111 and so on.
And we're going to sum them all
up to get the heat of
atomization -- compare it with
the actual heat of atomization.
Okay, so for ethene,
there are four C-H bonds,
there's one C-C double bond.
Add them up, and you get 542.
The actual heat of atomization
is 537.7.
So there's an error of 4.3
kilocalories/mol,
which is less than 1%.
That's pretty good.
But on the other hand,
ethene probably entered in to
determining these average bond
energies.
Right?
So it's not 100% fair. Okay?
How about cyclohexane?
Now we have 6 carbon-carbon
single bonds and 12
carbon-hydrogen single bonds:
1686 versus 1680.1.
An error of only 5.9,
less than half a percent error.
So pretty good,
by adding up bonds.
Cyclohexanol.
Remember we had quite a bit of
trouble with these partly
oxidized things before,
when we were trying to just do
it on the basis of the elements.
But if you add bonds together,
you get within 0.3% of the
right value.
Or if you do glucose,
which has lots of oxygens in
it, then you get within again
less then 1%;
0.7% of the right value.
So this is pretty darn good;
very impressive,
very small errors,
to predict these.
But the question is,
is it useful?
How accurate does it have to
be, to be useful?
So why do you need to know the
values?
Because you want to know
equilibrium constants.
You want to know which
direction a reaction will go,
for example.
Okay, so we know that the -- if
we want to calculate an
equilibrium constant,
we can do it at room
temperature with this 3/4ths
trick.
So the calculated equilibrium
constant is whatever we're
calculating here,
for energy, between two things.
We have two things:
calculate the energy of these,
the energy of these,
compare the energies,
and that'll give us the
equilibrium constant,
according to this formula.
But notice I'm doing it on the
basis of calculation.
Now so that's -- whatever --
the calculated energy is
whatever the true energy would
be.
But there's also some error in
there.
Okay?
But if you add two exponents,
that's the same as multiplying
two things together.
So the calculated equilibrium
constant is the true equilibrium
constant --
that's the first part,
the part that it has with
ΔH true --
times the part that has this
exponent.
Right?
3/4ths of the ΔH
error.
So if you want the error to be
small, that factor to be small,
then ΔH error has
to be small;
small, not on a percentage
basis, but absolutely it has to
be small.
That error, not the percentage
error, determines this error
factor.
Right?
So to keep the error less than
a factor of ten,
in the equilibrium constant,
you need to know the
equilibrium constants within 1.3
kilocalories/mol,
so that 3/4ths of it will be
one, and that would mean you'd
be within a factor of ten.
Everybody with me on this?
So you need to do even better
than this.
You can't use the average bond
energies and get something
that's very useful,
because if you're off by
sixteen down here,
in the case of sugar,
that means you're off by a
factor of 10^12th in predicting
the equilibrium constant,
which wouldn't be acceptable
probably.
Okay?
So let's try it with the
equilibrium between a ketone and
the so-called enol,
which is an isomer of a ketone
in which a hydrogen has been
taken from the methyl group on
the right and put on the oxygen,
and the double bond moved. Okay?
So that's a very important
equilibrium that we'll encounter
when we talk about the chemistry
of ketones.
Let's see what the equilibrium
constant -- should there be more
ketone or more enol?
Do you have a guess right at
the outset of which one would be
more stable?
I would guess the ketone,
because of what I just told
you, that the C-O double bond is
remarkably stable.
Right?
In the other case you have a
C-C double bond.
Okay, let's see.
Now we could add together all
the bonds.
But most of them,
most bonds are the same between
the starting material and
product.
We only need to compare the
ones that change.
Okay?
So we've highlighted in red the
bonds that change between the
two forms,
the two isomers,
because we're interested in the
difference in energy between
these two,
to get the equilibrium constant.
Okay, so these are the numbers
I took from the table,
that you see on the top left
there: 179 for C-O double bond
and so on.
And I sum them up and that's
361, for those bonds.
And the new set of bonds,
in the enol,
sum to 343.
So the ketone indeed is more
stable, it appears,
by 18 kilocalories/mol.
So 18 kilocalories/mol means
that you have a factor of
10^13th;
the equilibrium constant is
10^13.5.
So it should lie,
for practical purposes,
entirely in the direction of
the ketone.
However, if you do it
experimentally,
you find that the equilibrium
constant is only 10^7th,
not 10^14th.
Right?
So the true energy difference
is 9.3 kilocalories;
not the eighteen that we got by
adding bonds together.
Right?
So that means we're going to
have to deal with addressing why
the enol is too stable.
It's 9 kilocalories/mol too
stable, compared to our
predictions, on the basis of
adding bonds together.
Now why?
Well one thing is that we --
that those bonds that we
cancelled,
the C-H bonds that didn't
change, in fact did change
between the starting material
and the product.
Why could I say that they did
change?
In both cases,
on both sides,
there are single carbon-carbon,
carbon-hydrogen bonds.
How can I say they change?
Angela?
Student:  Well with the
ketone, they're sp^3
hybridized.
Prof: Ah ha.
Student:  In the enol
they're sp^2 hybridized.
Prof: Right.
They're changing hybridization.
Actually, yeah,
they go from sp^3 to
sp^2, on the carbon,
as you go across.
And the sp^2's on the
right should be more stable.
Okay?
So the sp^2-H should be
stronger.
So these things that I was
saying cancelled do not actually
cancel, if we take hybridization
into account.
So that's one factor.
And there's another as well,
which is you have that unshared
pair, on the top right here,
on the oxygen,
is adjacent to a double bond.
That means that this high HOMO
can be stabilized by the
π* low LUMO;
it'll overlap.
That isn't a possibility here,
where the unshared pairs on the
oxygen did not overlap with the
π* orbital.
So you get intramolecular
HOMO/LUMO mixing in the enol
that you don't get in the
ketone;
which will help stabilize the
enol, with that -- we could draw
that resonance structure.
So those two things together
make up that 9 kilocalorie
error;
or at least we can think --
they contribute to it at least.
So constitutional energy,
what we would get by adding
bonds together,
has to be corrected for various
"effects",
we'll call them,
such as resonance,
that's what we just looked at,
like this HOMO/LUMO thing,
such as hybridization changes,
or such as strain,
as in the case of axial
methylcyclohexane,
that we looked at.
So there are lots and lots of
these corrections that you have
to apply to this model,
where you add together bond
energies in order to predict the
energies of a particular
molecule.
But for many cases now,
you can do a pretty good job of
predicting these things,
and actually not do so bad at
predicting relative energies of
isomers,
and therefore equilibrium
constants.
And these effects,
of course, are a polite name
for error.
Right?
They're correcting -- various
ways of correcting errors that
you think there should be in
this scheme of just adding bonds
together.
Now, energy determines what can
happen.
Things always move toward
equilibrium.
Right?
So if the ratio of two things
is something,
but the equilibrium ratio is
different,
the ratio will always move
toward that,
toward the equilibrium,
if it's in isolation.
But there's another equally
important thing is how fast will
it go there?
And that, as we've seen before,
can be approximated as
10^13th/second,
times this same kind of factor,
relating to the barrier.
Now both of these things
suggest that being low in energy
is good.
Right?
You favor things that are low
in energy.
But you might ask why?
That's not what people say
about money.
They don't say the less money
you have the better.
Right?
Why the less energy the better?
This is a really interesting
case, and it has to do with
statistics.
And especially at Yale we
should talk about this,
because in 1902,
when Yale celebrated it's
bicentennial,
they published a number of
books showing off the
scholarship of Yale;
as you can see here.
And the most important of those
books,
by about 500 miles,
was this one:
Elementary Principles in
Statistical Mechanics and the
Rational Foundation of
Thermodynamics,
by J. Willard Gibbs.
So it's statistical mechanics.
It's trying to understand the
behavior of chemical substances,
on the basis of statistics.
Now when you do this,
you get exponents.
And the organization of our
presentation here is going to
have to do with three different
ways in which statistics enters
into exponents,
for purposes of doing
equilibrium.
So there's the Boltzmann Factor;
that's what we've been talking
about, the 10^(3/4
ΔH),
that's called the Boltzmann
Factor.
It includes the Boltzmann
Constant.
Then there are things that have
to do with entropy,
which often seems to be a very
confusing topic.
And finally there's a thing
called the Law of Mass Action.
And all of these things have
exponents in them.
And if you understand how the
exponents behave,
you understand what's going on.
So let's look first at the
Boltzmann Factor.
So here's Ludwig Boltzmann,
who committed suicide in 1906.
And this is his important paper
on "The Relationship
between the Second Law of
Thermodynamics and Probability
Calculations"
--
so statistics --
"Regarding the Laws of
Thermal Equilibrium,"
in 1877.
And his key equation is S =
k lnW . So log relates to an
exponential, and we'll see why
that is.
And here's his tombstone in the
cemetery in Vienna.
And you'll notice,
up at the top there,
S = k ln W.
Okay?
So what Boltzmann considered
was the implication of random
distribution of energy.
Suppose you have a certain
amount of energy,
in a system,
but it's distributed at random.
Right?
So purely statistically.
Then how should it be
distributed?
How much energy should any
particular molecule have,
is the question.
And we can visualize this in a
simple case, which is very like
what he did, except he did it
analytically and in a much
bigger system.
But just using four containers,
which are like molecules,
and each one can have a certain
amount of energy in it.
And we'll consider the energy
to be -- to come in bits.
He used that idea,
that there were bits of energy
to be distributed among
molecules, or degrees of freedom
within molecules.
He didn't think that energy
came in bits,
but it made it possible to do
the statistics,
and then he just took the limit
when these bits get very,
very, very, very small,
so that it becomes like a
continuum of stuff,
like a whole sand of energy
bits.
But anyhow, let's just count up
how many different ways there
are of putting three different
bits of energy --
or actually not different,
they're all the same --
but three bits of energy into
the red container.
Okay?
So if you -- how many
complexions --
that's what,
any particular arrangement he
called a complexion --
how many different complexions
have a certain number of bits in
the first container?
Well suppose you put all three
of those energy bits into the
first container.
How many different ways are
there of doing that?
Just one. Okay?
But suppose you put only two
into the first container?
Now how many different ways are
there of arranging it so that
there are two in the first
container?
How many different ways?
There are three: 1,2, 3.
So there'll be three ways of
putting two bits in the first
container.
How many of putting one in the
first container?
Well we put one there;
there's 1,2,
3,4, 5,6 ways of doing it.
Okay?
So there's six ways of putting
one in there.
And how many of putting none at
all in there?
1,2, 3,4, 5,6, 7,8, 9,10. Okay?
So there are 10 ways of doing
that.
So let's make a graph and see
how many ways -- what's the
probability that you'll have a
certain number of bits of energy
in the first container?
Okay, it looks like that:
10,6, 3,1.
And what does that curve look
like, if you made a plot of
that?
What type of curve does it look
like?
Is it a straight line?
Anybody got a name for it,
or something that looks a
little bit like that?
Student:  Exponential.
Prof: It's exponential
decay.
Now it's not truly exponential,
in this case,
of three bits among four
containers.
But if you do 30 bits among 20
containers, then it looks like
that, and there is an
exponential.
Right?
So what Boltzmann was able to
do, to show mathematically,
was that the limit,
when you have very many,
very small energy bits,
is truly an exponential.
So the probability of having a
certain amount of energy,
in a degree of freedom,
is exponential:
e^-(whatever that energy is,
divided by kT).
So Boltzmann showed that that
was the limit for lots of
infinitesimal energy bits.
And the idea behind it is quite
clear.
If all the complexions for a
given total are equally likely
-- and that's what he assumes;
it's random,
they can be any place they want
to be -- then shifting energy
into any one degree of freedom,
of one molecule,
is disfavored.
Because when you put more in
one molecule,
there are fewer ways to
distribute the rest among the
others.
So there'll be fewer ways,
the more you put in this one.
Is that clear?
Because that's really the key
concept.
The more bits of energy you put
in this one, the fewer different
ways there are of permuting
what's left among the others.
Right?
And it's exponential. Right?
So if you have fewer ways among
the others, then it's less
likely.
Right?
So it turns out that if you do
this, the average energy is
½ kT,
in this degree of freedom;
which is to say that k,
the Boltzmann Constant,
relates temperature to average
energy;
which is to say that
temperature is
average energy.
Temperature and average energy
at equilibrium are the same
thing -- okay?
-- for each degree of freedom.
You can put -- what did we mean
by these little buckets into
which we could put energy?
We had a way of putting energy
into the molecule,
like stretching this bond,
or stretching this bond,
or bending some bonds,
or torsion, or something like
that.
Now truly, we deal with quantum
states.
So you put energy into
different quantum states and you
count up the quantum states,
to see how likely things are.
Okay, so that's where the
Boltzmann Factor is.
That exponential,
that e to the -- exponential
¾ ΔH comes
just because that's what you
expect.
If you randomly distribute
things, it'll come out that way.
Now how about the entropy
factor?
And this one is fun.
Feynman, in his wonderful
Lectures on Physics,
says: "It is the change
from an ordered arrangement to a
disordered arrangement,
which is the source of
irreversibly."
Have you heard this said,
that entropy is disorder,
and that you increase entropy
in order to increase disorder?
Okay, so that's what Feynman is
saying here.
"The change from an
ordered arrangement to a
disordered arrangement."
Okay.
Now here are two arrangements
of the same number of dots.
Which one is more ordered,
left or right?
Students:  Left.
Prof: Okay.
You know I'm setting you up,
right?
So you're -- but I know what
you would have voted for.
Right?
So I'm not going to ask you to
vote.
Okay?
But look at the one on the
right, from a different point of
view.
>
So what do you conclude?
Which one is more ordered?
The one on the right is just as
ordered as the one on the left,
but we didn't perceive the
order.
Okay?
And that's like constellations;
you know, the shepherds lay out
and saw bears and dragons and
things, in the sky -- right?
-- and thought they were
ordered.
Okay?
Now disorder,
reversibility and Couette flow.
Now I brought an experiment to
do here, and it's -- but I'm not
really sure it would work.
So what I'm going to do --
because I didn't practice it
before I came.
I've done it before,
but I didn't practice it today,
and my pipette broke and I had
to get a new one made before
class.
So if you want to see that,
come after class and we'll try
the actual experiment.
But I'm going to show you a
movie of it instead.
Here.
So this is the same thing here.
What it is, is a -- well you'll
see in the movie.
I'll just start it up.
>
Prof: Okay,
so it's a glass rod that goes
up inside a glass cylinder.
So there's like a doughnut
inside, right?
So I'm now going to pour Karo
syrup in there;
I brought Karo syrup with me to
show you.
So it's in that annulus between
the rod and the cylinder.
Okay?
And now I'm going to take some
yellow dye and put a strip of it
--
first I'm going to mark it,
so I can tell --
I'm going to rotate that
outside cylinder,
so you can see that it's
rotating.
And I'm putting a strip of
yellow dye between the rod and
the cylinder.
Everybody see what I'm doing?
And then I'm going to stir it
up.
And the way I'm going to stir
it is by rotating the outside
cylinder.
Okay, so we'll zoom in and
you'll see the watch,
not very well,
but to show that I'm not just
running the movie backward or
anything.
Okay?
Okay, now I start rotating the
outside.
So there's one rotation,
two rotations,
three rotations.
So now it's all mixed up.
And now watch.
I'm unrotating.
And it comes back.
So if you want to see that
happen, we'll try it after class
here.
Student:  Oh wow.
Prof: So you unmix
things.
That doesn't sound like entropy
is working right.
Okay?
Now here's the way it actually
happened.
So there was the syrup,
between the rod and the
cylinder --
a look down from the top -- and
we put a strip of ink in
between,
and then started rotating.
And as we rotated,
the ink spread out,
like this.
Right?
Because the outer part moved,
and the inner part didn't move,
where it was in contact with
the rod.
So after I'd done three
rotations, it looked like that.
It wasn't really evenly mixed
up.
It's just that when we looked
at it, it looked like it was
mixed up -- right?
-- when we looked through it.
And now when we unrotate it,
the whole thing -- nothing
diffused and molecules didn't
move at random.
They just got spread out that
way, but in a particular way.
So it came back again. Okay?
So the rotated state only
seemed to be
disordered.
So that's the basis of the
trick.
Right?
But that raises a very
fundamental question.
If disorder is in the mind of
the beholder --
in this case,
or in the case of that
dinosaur,
connect the dots -- if disorder
is in the mind of the beholder,
how can it measure a
fundamental property,
like entropy,
if it depends on who's looking
at it,
to say whether it's disordered
or not?
Right?
In fact, a disordered
arrangement is an oxymoron,
because arrangement is
arrangement, and disordered is
not arrangement.
Right?
So how can you have a
disordered arrangement,
if the shepherd sees a dragon?
Okay?
The situation favored at
equilibrium,
by entropy, is one where
particles have diffused every
which-away,
not into a coiled up piece of
paper like the yellow thing,
or not into a dinosaur.
Every which-away;
the key word is 'every'.
That's what's statistical about
it.
A disordered arrangement is a
code word for a collection of
random distributions,
whose individual structures are
not obvious.
So if a thing looks like,
you know, a regular lattice
like that, I say,
"Ah ha,
that's a regular lattice."
But if it looks like this,
I don't say it's exactly that;
I say it's disordered,
by which I mean I can't tell
the difference between that one
and this one,
or this one,
or this one.
Right?
So there are a whole bunch of
those arrangements that I count
together when I say
'disordered'.
It's a collective word.
So if all of them are equally
likely,
it's much more likely to have
disordered --
many, many, many arrangements
-- than the particular ordered
ones that we're thinking about,
even if they're all equally
likely.
So that's the idea.
It is favored at equilibrium
because it includes so many
individual distributions.
So entropy is actually
counting, in disguise.
You count all these different
arrangements,
or all the different quantum
levels,
and the more you have,
under a certain name,
the higher the entropy
associated with that name is.
So, for example,
a very common value of the
entropy difference between two
things is 1.377 entropy units.
That seems a weird number,
right?
Now 1.377 happens to be
R times the natural log
of two.
Now, consider the difference in
entropy between gauche and
anti-butane.
Okay?
So the equilibrium constant is
e^(-ΔG/RT).
Do you remember what G
is?
That's the Gibbs Free Energy,
which includes both heat,
both the kind of things -- bond
energy that we've been talking
about --
and entropy is included in
there too.
So we can split it apart,
into the part that has to do
with heat --
or enthalpy,
the ΔH between the
two things,
gauche and anti -- and
TΔS,
the part that has to do with
entropy.
I suspect you've seen this
G=H+TS before;
H-TS before.
But let's just split it apart.
Since they're in the exponent
we can multiply two things
together.
So we have the first part,
the one we've been dealing
with, 3/4thsΔH.
Right?
And then we have the red part,
that has to do with entropy.
But you can simplify that.
How can you simplify the part
that has to do with entropy,
right off the bat?
Student: Cancel the
T's.
Prof: Cancel the
Okay, so it's actually
ΔS/R.
Now suppose that the value of
ΔS is Rln2;
which I said was a very common
entropy difference.
Right?
Now you can simplify it further.
Can you see how to simplify it
further, for that particular
entropy difference?
Well obviously the R's cancel.
And what's E raised to
the power ln2?
Student:  Two.
Prof: Two.
So actually what that is,
is our 3/4thsΔH
times two.
So when you see 1.377 entropy
units, that's somebody who likes
math telling you that's there a
factor of two involved.
That sounds more reasonable.
Right?
Two.
Why should there be a factor of
two, that favors gauche- over
anti-butane?
Yes?
Student:  There are
twice as many gauches.
Prof: There are twice as
many gauches as there are
anti's, because it can be
right-handed or left-handed
gauche.
So you see what a crock this
is, to say that the entropy
difference between gauche- and
anti-butane is 1.377 entropy
units?
It's just that there are twice
as many of one as the other.
Right?
So that, the fact that
ΔS occurs in an
exponent, is just a complicated
way of telling you that there's
a statistical factor.
You have to count how many of
these things there are.
Okay?
Because you have two gauche
butanes.
So the conclusion;
it just means a factor of two.
And then that the equilibrium
constant depends on temperature,
because of ΔH,
not because of ΔS.
Often people think that because
the free energy is H and
TS, that therefore the
entropy thing is changing as
T changes.
But in fact that's not true,
because you divide by T
to get anything out of it again.
Right?
So what really changes with
temperature is the contribution
due to ΔH.
So sometimes that's just used
to obscure what is fundamentally
very simple.
Okay, we're going to stop here.
And just so everybody's on the
same page, we'll have the final
lecture on Wednesday.
But then I'll be here at class
time on Friday too,
and we can have a discussion
then, to review for the exam.
And I'm willing to have another
one.
I forget.
When did I say? On Monday night.
Now do people have -- there are
not exams at night,
are there; or are there?
Does anybody have a -- is
Monday night okay to have the
review?
It's probably the best time to
have it, so you have a full day
after that before the exam.
So I'll get a room for next
Monday night,
a week from tonight,
for a review session.
But also I'll be here on Friday
at lecture time.
So we'll see you.
If anybody wants to see this
experiment, we'll do it.